how about we do this
u.s job openings surpassed 10.9 million
the number of open jobs in america is
greater than the number of unemployed
people and that's two months in a row
now now last month they filled close to
a million jobs but at 10.1 million
openings that was a record and that
meant there were more openings than
people available to work
sit from april to july
we lost 3 million jobs per month about
just shy of 3 million but only gained
about a couple hundred thousand per
month so it was like for every three
jobs lost one job has been gained
the economy is not doing well
you look at all the shortages all the
shutdown
and there's still people in this country
who are like yeah joe biden the economy
is doing pretty good and i have no idea
how that's possible but i'll tell you
this
if these people
at cnn and msnbc continue to push this
stuff
they are they're the people who are
stripping the copper out of the walls of
the building we're in to go sell for
scrap they're the people who saw the
iceberg that saw the titanic hit the
iceberg now they're stealing all the
fine china and silverware and russian
lifeboats
they're extracting everything while the
ship is sinking it's why rachel maddow
uh she went from a daily show now she's
doing a weekly show a lot of people have
pointed out yeah she's jumping [ __ ] she
doesn't want to be left holding the bag
so she's reducing her workload taking a
bigger paycheck
i can't remember who told us it might
have been bannon that jon stewart
shut his show down just before trump
came in because they all knew it was
going to happen and nobody wanted to be
doing a nightly show where they're
forced to lie
so they cancel it and that's basically i
think what we're going through right now
is like you take a look at you know
someone like ian who by any any sane
metric a conservative would call a
leftist a liberal or you know at the
very least on the left
yet people in media would say ian's far
right
it's because i have long hair
i think that's a reason to make you far
left people look at me and they make
assumptions yeah yeah
well we're trapped in this
you know so i think ultimately what this
brit what this brings us to is we're
watching the the country collapse it's
breaking apart
portland announces they're banning trade
with texas california says no travel to
other states i'm like yo at this point
this is one by one the bricks falling
out of the building as the united states
is crumbling down
and so long i think i think the main
issue is
you've got people on the left who
actively want that to happen the occupy
wall street people for instance were
like very much so wanting the us to
collapse antifa very clearly wants the
us to collapse the they they all
basically think this country is racist
6019 project all that stuff and one by
one our institutions are failing it's no
surprise the people in government are
incentivized to extract as much as they
can as the ship is is falling apart and
what's what's the end result i guess we
break apart
that's what
should have happened a long time ago
i mean how do you
you have people who are like okay i
literally want to be able to have a baby
be born
and punch a hole in its head and suck
its brain out
that was in virginia yeah they literally
want that to happen how am i supposed to
share air with them how am i supposed to
share a polity with them
i mean
why should i be why should i be forced
to
why don't we just break up and the
hardest part is you have states where
a state like texas okay
you have the dallas fort worth area
dallas is insanely left fort worth is
right
so how do you do that
you have to come up we have to come up
with a way that people can be able to
choose the kind of governance they want
because we're just going to be at war to
the point where
oh i don't know people are burning
cities down i mean i i
those cities need to be abandoned i was
joking because it already happened right
right this past weekend in the past
weekend there's been shootouts in
portland uh so i i personally think that
that
there needs to be a unifying principle
around which people can gather
in order to have a a strong country
right you talked i think you were right
that how the modern day right
conservatives for the last 50 years have
ceded uh the our education system
entertainment and the media to the left
and we're reaping the consequences of
that today right and i think part of
part of that is when you teach kids you
talk about this critical race theory
stuff and
um and and and certainly in college for
a long time it was happening in college
where people
students were being taught
to think this country was a horrible
place an evil place where everyone was
racist
we came up i grew up you know and was
taught you know we judge people by the
content of their character not the color
of their skin like we read martin luther
king we ingested it we believed it and
but today
your child in a public school is being
taught that they're either a victim or a
press presser based on the color of
their skin they're taught to
hate the other based on the color of
their skin and when that happens i mean
you start to believe in ways especially
if you're a little one right that your
country is a fundamentally evil horrible
place and and that's why we have such
unbelievable group polarization in this
country because we've had one political
party
who has done nothing but divide us among
age race demographic you know young old
rich poor black white christian atheist
because that's how they maintain power
right i have a different view and you
and i have
talked about this in the show or even
debated about it a little bit but i i
you know maybe it's me being naive but i
believe that what makes america
exceptional is is not necessarily our
diversity now diversity is great like
around this table we have an
unbelievable amount of diversity and
diversity of thought is great because it
challenges us
to to to think in different ways but but
but what makes this country exceptional
is that for
you know 200 years we've put aside our
petty differences or done the best that
we could in order to put us put aside
our differences and united around the
principle of being an american today we
don't have that anymore and you see
little fractures in every aspect of what
we do in our education system even in
sports now or political right i mean you
know how we solve it
sean parnell does not run for senate in
u.s senate he runs for mayor of his
hometown he runs for mayor of his
hometown and he and he
gets people elected to the board who
agree with him and say we're not going
to teach that crap here
the federal gop is controlled opposition
for the regime we know that even kevin
even kevin um
kevin mccarthy the minority leader he in
the house yeah in the house he was oh so
oh i'm a total trumper until january 6
and then he starts backing off and then
he starts going back look at what
desantis is doing in florida look at
what abbott is doing in texas if sean
parnell ran for governor of pennsylvania
and ran on three things you're not
teaching that crap in schools um
if you don't want a mask on your child
you're not gonna have a mask and if you
don't want a needle stuck in your arm
you don't have to have a needle stuck in
your arm if you ran for for governor of
pennsylvania on that you would get
elected and you would do more for the
people that you love in your home state
than you would going to washington dc
and getting stuck in that mess i i don't
disagree with what you're saying
um
i i do think that there are many
positive ways that you especially if
you're getting elected and the idea that
all politics is local right and like
we're seeing just in pennsylvania alone
like an unbelievably intense focus on
school boards
we've never seen anything like the
intensity that's around school board
elections this year but we're seeing
that at every level and mayor governor
there's a gubernatorial election in
pennsylvania in 2022 and i would say 99
of the time i would agree with you
except for 2022
if we lose the state of pennsylvania
which is a republic this seat senator
toomey's retiring it's an open seat so
there's no incumbent there
it's been in republican control for a
while
um if we lose the seat and the democrats
of course know that there's no pathway
to the senate majority without flipping
the seat in pennsylvania they have to do
it if they want an actual majority
then it almost doesn't matter if there's
a republican governor in pennsylvania
because the feds whether it's with hr1
uh the the you know the
for the people act or senate bill one
which is basically a nationalization of
our of our elections the feds are taking
away power from the states
at a rate that has
never been seen before
in american history
and
the critical fight for me is is in the
senate to stop the radical left from
packing the supreme court from nuking
the filibuster to making washington dc
and puerto rico a state
it doesn't matter if there's a
republican governor in pennsylvania of
course it does of course it does i'd
rather see a republican there than a
radical leftist but i'm saying
i i don't want to see
states stripped of of their power and
and the left today will absolutely do
that they're not shy about their agenda
and for me so i see not only is
leadership important less political
party to me and leadership is actually
what really matters
uh but being winning the seat in
pennsylvania defending pennsylvania but
also defending the country against being
a hedge against
just the insane radicalism of the new
democratic party and not allowing them
to fundamentally transform this country
into something that we've never
recognized before i think you actually
you know what you're saying is another
reason
he could win the senate if you campaign
in the same things the state level not
you know the kids your schools school
boards you know vaccine choosing to get
vaccinated or whatever school choice is
something that is unbelievably important
and and so i think covet and these
insane lockdowns have shown us this
something crosses you know uh
socioeconomic strata
it's important in the inner city it's
important in the royal community
especially in pennsylvania where
broadband is a real issue when schools
closed and
we went virtual there were kids in the
inner city that didn't have a laptop
computer to get on the internet or
didn't have access to the internet you
had kids in rural communities who were
climbing to the tops of their silos in
the hopes that they could get on the
internet and the starbucks across town
because they didn't have broadband
internet they had no internet whatsoever
so you're right there are those very
same issues like i'm vehemently opposed
to vaccine mandates i will say that like
as you as you mentioned if you want the
vaccine consult with your doctor by all
means get the vaccine but let no
government
um i think it uh
so the government doesn't know
your personal life they don't know your
personal finances
they don't know the struggles you go
through
but and this tends to be
republicans do this like you mentioned
the the federal gop is just opposition
control that position
they they they do these blanket policies
that don't make sense for localities so
they're the one thing i think people
definitely need to pay attention to as
you mentioned school boards are really
important uh they're so important but i
i will say too i i think you're correct
they need a better governor in in in
pennsylvania
john would be a great governor but
if shawna is going to get that senate
seat and it's going to have a big impact
at the federal level even if the federal
gop is uh controlled opposition i think
that's actually a good argument for why
more
honest
individuals should be running and
displacing this is why i wanted
i think desantis has done more
to protect his
constituency than probably any
politician in
my life you're you're 100 you're 100
right and he's doing that at the and
he's doing that at the governor level
while he's being attacked well and he's
just middle finger so this is this is
the point that i wanted to make and i by
the way
you're right i think ron desantis has
done an incredible job in florida
you're right uh all my life i have
wondered why
republicans
haven't fought harder right i think
there's a lot of reasons why i think a
lot of republicans don't want the media
attention they want to fight the media
and the democrats a lot of that
but what trump taught the republican
party and certainly this next wave of
sort of republican blue collar working
the party of the see the republican
party is the party of the working class
individual freedom and liberty small
federal government all all the same
stuff but the but the
trump taught this next generation of
republicans how to fight
and and that the cultural fight is also
important and it cannot simply be
discarded right and
some of us have been trying to teach
libertarians that too
well
well i i so i i do think that that that
we can change the whole uh uniparty
because there are times where i'm so
frustrated
at how the republican party operates but
the only way you change it is to get
involved and and be the change that that
you hope to see
but that that's why it's we can stop
we can stop the insanity you're talking
about the usa and an empire in decline
america in decline or late stage
collapse i don't i don't i don't buy i
don't buy that uh
i think that good strong leadership can
change it but impend if we win
pennsylvania we can stop the insanity of
the radical left that all rests on
pennsylvania i'm telling you
that we can stop them from
doing what they're doing to this country
and that's why pennsylvania is so
important and that's why
that's why the radical left and people
like chuck schumer were running ads
against me two weeks before i was even a
candidate because they know how
important it is thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time